as he was renamed is one of three
elephants brought to Sri Lanka as gifts
from Thailand's royal family
but the sick elephant is at the center
of a diplomatic Rift between the two
countries
Thailand demanded the elephant's return
after animal rights activists accused
handlers at a temple of torturing the
animal since 2020 we have been trying to
get help from uttaraja from Sri Lankan
authorities we contacted the Department
of Wildlife Conservation we conducted
National Geological Gardens department
and he is contacted the ministry of
wildlife but they refused healthy
because he was a foreign elephant and
because his life was in danger we had no
choice but to contact the Thai
government
Raja was brought to this zoo on the
outskirts of Sri Lanka's Capital Colombo
with wounds and a stiff leg from an
untreated injury
vets preparing to fly him back to
Thailand on Sunday for further treatment
at the time of his arrival his condition
was not that good he was in you know
medically he was not well enough but at
present his condition has improved very
much
muthu Roger spent decades taking part in
religious processions as a temple
elephant but villagers reported seeing
him overworked at logging sites and even
used in tourist Safaris
activists who launched the campaign to
rescue him hoped he would retire in Sri
Lanka
now they say muthuraja deserves a better
life after Decades of service and
suffering Barbara angupa Al Jazeera
still ahead